all right now tonight following the path
of new york governor cuomo
dr doom gloom flip-flop pouchy is now
using his pandemic failures to cash in
on a book deal about
quote truth and service now remember it
was just last week that fauci flipped
and flopped and flowed
on the lab leak theory oh maybe it is
possible
and of course we've documented right
here on this program he's flip-flopped
on everything from
ass can't fix anything they won't do
anything to one mass to two mass to mass
once a season
he flip-flopped on ventilators schools
and reopenings and the
risk of outdoor transmission to the
threshold needed for herd immunity and
so on and so forth
and then of course the issue of the gain
of
function research being done at the
wuhan lab at the nih apparently partly
funded
now the book's reportedly only 80 pages
long no word on whether it will address
all the controversy surrounding gain of
function research
and now fauci still refuses to give a
straight answer on that but
back in 2012 fouchy claimed the benefits
of this controversial gain of function
research
outweighed any risk of a pandemic
dr fauci still believe that and one of
the senators who has been forcing
voucher to actually answer the tough
questions
he's from the great state of louisiana
senator john kennedy
and by the way senator i strongly unless
you ask me not to
uh strongly support your reelection you
have done a phenomenal job
as a senator from the great state of
louisiana and uh you become a true
leader in the senate
and i have a great admiration for you
sir
well uh thank you sean um
my campaign people would beat me about
the head and shoulders if i didn't ask
folks to
to go to my website john kennedy dot com
john kennedy dot com i put up some
cool new pictures and some some
admonitions
to folks like pretty pleased with sugar
on top
uh stand your ass up for the national
anthem and that sort of
but stuff i say a word about go ahead
about dr fauci yes sir um
let me let me say this about dr fauci i
know dr fauci i like dr fauci i respect
dr fouch but karma
as they say is a witch
for the record that's witch
the evidence has finally caught up
with the chinese communist party with dr
fauci and with the other permanent
washington types
who for over a year have said that the
idea
that the coronavirus came from a china
lab leak
was a conspiracy theory and that anybody
believed that was circus freak crazy
well it wasn't a conspiracy theory and
people aren't
circus freak crazy it was a reasonable
question to ask from day
one suspicious facts
have existed from day one if people
cared to look
pointing to that possibility the
chinese communist party and dr fauci
and i'm going to be blunt here have said
for over a year look nothing to see
here the coronavirus came from an animal
except after a year no one's been able
to prove that
and as the economist magazine put it
this week
no one has found anything close to a
smoking bat
not to put too fine a point on it but uh
a year ago this month in may of 2020
my friend dr fauci gave her a number of
interviews
and in them he dismissed the lab leak
theory
now i want to be fair to him i know the
press was all over him and he did it
under pressure from the press
but dr falci should have told the press
to stick it up their fact checker
that i'm going to follow the science and
he didn't
and we've lost a year here and and i
don't know
if we'll ever find the origin of the
virus now
it's not a question sean of keeping
score or who was right or nan and now
you were wrong
we need to know this so that we can keep
it from happening
a gain and i don't know now
uh if we'll ever find out and that's a
that's a bloody shame
you know he he's flipped and flopped and
failed now the comments in 2012 about
gain of function
this is significant in other words labs
that actually
they manipulate and i'm using layman's
terms here forgive me senator i'm not a
doctor and i'm not a medical researcher
but manipulate
viruses but it causes the
it it can potentially and he
acknowledged that it can potentially
cause a pandemic that gets out of
control
he said it was worth the effort yes he
was in charge of the nih
he gave money to the wuhan lab he can't
say
based on your questioning of him whether
or not any of that money was used that
way is that correct sir
yes and i don't know that that's dr
fauci's call
or the call of any other scientist or
or washington dc insider look
this is what we discovered scientists
all over the world
are creating frankensteins that's what
gain of function research is
in gain of function research a scientist
in a lab
takes a harmless benign pathogen
and turns it into a deadly
contagious virus to learn from it
and this is happening all over the world
and labs leak and we didn't know about
it
and dr fauci and his colleagues they're
going to have to step up
and tell us what's going on here and
whether the american people are paying
for it
all right well congratulations again
senator on your announcement for your
reelection we always love having you on
appreciate you being
pushing this issue hard we need to know
thank you sir
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else